Halloween's around the corner so expect
to see costumes that are clever topical
or that put a sexy spin on just about
any job insect or Disney character
imaginable but guys there's a fine line
between being creative and being
distasteful and the parties have already
started let's take a look at this year's
most ridiculous inappropriate Halloween
costumes already trending online Ebola
may be the biggest news story right now
but it doesn't mean it has to be your
costume I'm talking about the sex Ebola
nurse Frank Conniff tweeted wearing a
sexy bola nurse Halloween costume is a
surefire way to get yourself pouran teen
from all decent human beings he has a
point
cuz last I checked ain't nothing sexy
about Ebola and it's probably not the
most tactful way to pay tribute to all
the health workers or victims out there
what's the point of a protective suit is
to cover every inch of your skin I think
they missed a few and then there's the
Ray Rice costume bringing blackface and
the glorification of domestic violence
together in one astoundingly non-pc
getup kids are even wearing it
Wendy Aaron's tweeted I wish we could
use democracy to vote people like the
couple who dressed in blackface is Ray
Rice and his abuse life out of the
country let's not forget the complete
lack of sensitivity to domestic violence
victims
janay rice herself denounced the costume
saying it's sad that my suffering amuses
others but wait having fun at the
expense of others misfortunes doesn't
and there this Halloween Kris FET wrote
I'm still waiting on the Darren Wilson
Michael Brown costume you know it's
coming you're right Chris mud shark
Molly of already working on earth things
I need for my Michael Brown costume six
bullet wounds siga Rios saggy pants but
we've seen this movie before last year
several Halloween goers dressed up a
slain teenager Trayvon Martin and his
acquitted killer George Zimmerman here's
a tip don't dress up as murder teenagers
whose death sparked racial debates and
protests and just stop wearing blackface
it's racist and if you're still trying
to go for a topical costume please avoid
the predictable Isis fighter yes they're
scary
but despite the thought that went into
this grandpa's Isis inspired costumes or
your boy vanilla Isaac says get up show
it's not cool to make light of people
committing heinous acts the sad thing is
culturally inappropriate costumes are
not new we see them every year from
blackface tanta mamas - sexy Native
Americans - want to be geishas you get
the idea
so does Halloween give anyone a free
pass to dress up in the most non-pc
costumes they can think up or should
spokes try to be a bit more sensitive
where do you draw the line want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your App Store
now